Our first guest tonight
is a Grammy-nominated musician
and actor whose new series,
"Unidentified with Demi Lovato,"
is streaming on September 30th
on Peacock.
Let's take a look.
-You find something?
-Well, I don't totally know.
-What?
-It's not moving.
But it's bright like a star.
-But it's long.
-That is actually very strange.
-Yeah, do you see that?
-Isn't that weird?
More like a line than a dot.
-The rest of them are all...
-Normal stars.
-...perfectly round.
-Okay.
So if the one with...
-Yeah, that's it.
You're dead on, Demi.
-Please welcome back
to the show and the studio
our friend Demi Lovato.
♪♪
-Hi.
-It's so good to see you.
Thanks for being here.
-Thank you.
Hello.
♪♪
-Welcome back. It's so nice to
have you here in person again.
-Thank you.
It's so nice to be here.
Thank you for having me.
-Last time we talked,
I think it was in November
and you were telling me
that you were getting
into meditating.
Have you continued to meditate,
as we are here
almost a year later?
-Yes.
I have stayed meditating.
I meditated just this morning
and, you know,
yesterday morning,
and it's been good.
-Do you use an app?
I feel like a lot of people
are using apps now to meditate.
-I do use an app sometimes.
Sometimes, I use Insight Timer.
-Okay.
-Which is really, really good
for, like, guided meditations.
You can click, you know,
how long the meditation is
that you want to do,
and then just go from there.
But other times, I just meditate
by myself and...
-How much time do you feel
like you need to give yourself
on any given day to meditate?
-I like to give myself --
You know, in the beginning,
I was really, really into it,
and I was giving myself
like 30 minutes.
Then that turned into
like an hour,
then it turned into
an hour and a half.
And now it's back down
to like 10 minutes.
[ Laughs ]
It didn't stay that...
-Well, you're very busy.
-Yes.
-I would find it hard to believe
that you had 90 minutes
every day to meditate.
-I did in quarantine.
-Okay, right.
That's a good point, yes.
-And now I'm not in quarantine.
-You're back in the world,
and we're very happy
to have you back in the world
because we have
this wonderful show now.
The subject matter of this show
comes as no surprise to me.
The first time we met
was back in 2014,
the first year of this show.
-Yes.
-You came in.
We talked a lot about
how you were a believer
in the extraterrestrial,
the world of ghosts, mermaids.
-Yes.
-Which I -- This was stuff
that I didn't know about you.
I was delighted to hear.
And how -- So what do you
set out to do in the show?
-So, what I'm trying
to set out to do in the show
is just to gather evidence,
gather information
and try to make the best --
best guess of what
it might be that's out there.
-Part of this, of course,
must be the fun of the journey
because these are gonna be
really hard answers to find.
You're doing it with people
you obviously get along with
and love very much.
That's one of the joys
of the show.
Talk about who you are
doing this with.
-I am doing this
with my best friend,
Matthew Scott Montgomery,
and my older sister,
Dallas Lovato.
And it was just so much fun to
shoot with them because they --
Well, first, Matthew and I
always have a blast together.
And then, second, it was really,
really great to spend time
with my older sister
because you know
when you get older,
you just don't get to spend
as much time
around your family members
as you once did.
-Of course.
-And so it's really,
really nice to be able
to build our relationship
and have fun together doing
stuff that we all really enjoy.
-So you're obviously
the believer of the group.
Are either of them the skeptic?
Do you have a skeptic?
-They are more skeptical
than I am.
And I would say
the skeptic of the group
would have to be Matthew.
Matthew is very, very skeptical.
I mean, he was basically you.
[ Laughs ]
He was you out there.
-I'm glad.
I want to make sure that
I'm represented on this show,
even though
I'm very happy to say
I get to make a little cameo
in the show.
-Yes.
-I appear via Zoom
and got to talk to you about
some of the stuff
you're discovering.
And one of the cool things
is you are talking to people
who believe they've had these
extraterrestrial interactions,
scientists.
How do you put together
this list of the people
that you want
to talk to for the show?
-Well, the list actually came
from some of the producers.
The producers had worked
on various projects
that were UFO and ET-related,
so they had
all of the connections.
And all I did basically was
just go along for the ride.
And I was like a kid
in a candy shop.
I was so excited
to meet these people
who had had these
firsthand experiences and --
Wow. Did they have a lot to say.
-So you went
to a support group.
Is that -- Am I using
the terminology right?
Of people who, you know,
believe that they've sort of
had these moments?
-Yes.
-And when you went,
what did they sort of tell you
when you go into the room?
Did they want you to ask
a lot of questions or...?
-I basically went and just
listened for most of it.
It felt like a --
It felt like a support group
that, you know --
but for people
who have had experiences
with ETs, UFOs.
And when I first went in there,
I was just, like, in awe
at some of the things
that I was hearing,
and it also didn't
make me feel so alone.
Because there's a lot of times
when I tell people
that I believe in this stuff,
they look at me like
I've lost my marbles,
and that's okay.
But, yeah.
It was cool to talk to a bunch
of people that also believe
in some of the things
that I do and realize,
oh, we're kind of all
in this together.
-Are you worried that
by doing a show like this,
it will make ETs less likely
to interact with you in the fear
that they might get
caught on camera?
Like, I feel like each
of these interviews we do,
that if an ET is watching it,
they'd be like,
"Well, Seth's the one
we should [bleep] with
because, like,
he's the one who deserves it."
But they'll just stay
clear of you.
-Well, I've come to learn
that the way
to make these interactions
with these beings
are by expanding
our consciousness.
So, through meditation,
we actually can make contact
a lot easier,
and it's been so many times
where I've been meditating,
and I've looked up, and
there's something in the sky.
And so I think that
through meditation,
you can make it happen yourself.
-You also did --
You went under hypnosis
to see if you had
any sort of past experiences.
-Yes.
-Why did they discover?
Or what did you discover,
I should say, when you did that?
-Well, I would tell you, but
you have to watch to find out.
-All right. That's very fair.
-You know?
Because if I give it away...
-Hey, look,
I'm in the TV business.
I have a lot of respect
for what you just did.
-Okay, thank you.
-What about --
You also have a podcast now.
-Yes.
-And this is not unique
to just extraterrestrial stuff,
or is it?
-Right. No, it is not
just for UFOs and ETs.
It is -- I talk about
a plethora of topics.
I talk to friends of mine
that are in the industry,
people that aren't
in the industry,
people that are scientists,
just people that know a lot
about a lot of stuff,
and I am just interested in
learning what they have to say.
-You've always struck me
as very thoughtful and curious.
Do you like being someone
who asks the questions
as opposed
to getting them asked?
-I do, I really do,
because I love learning.
And I feel like I get to learn
so much more
by listening than I do talking.
[ Laughter ]
-That's why I just like to talk.
-[ Laughs ] Got it.
-I feel like I know
everything I want to know.
-Got it.
-Hey, it's always such
a pleasure to have you here.
-It's such a pleasure.
-Thanks for making the time.
"Unidentified with Demi Lovato"
is available to stream
on Peacock on September 30th.
That is technically right now.